صحيفه بوليتيكو كتبت ان استهداف القيادي
البارز في حماس صالح العاروري يمثل تصعيدا
خطيرا في الصراع القائم في الشرق الاوسط
الصحيفه تذكر بتصريحات سابقه لحسن نصر
الله توعد فيها بالرد على اي عمليه
استهداف تنفذها اسرائيل ضد اي مسؤول
فلسطيني في
لبنان الوس جوننا نشرت تقريرا يرى ان
اسرائيل ما زالت منقسمه على الرغم من
اظهار الوحده خلال حرب ويتابع التقرير
بالقول ان البلاد تواجه حاله من عدم
اليقين على مستوى العديد من الجبهات
ويستدل على ذلك بالتنبيه الى ان حكم
المحكمه العليا ياتي للتذكير بتلك
الانقسامات التي ستبرز بمجرد انتهاء
الحرب في صحيفه جلوبال تايمز الصينيه نقرا
ان سحب جزء من القوات الاسرائيليه يدل على
ان اسرائيل بحاجه لتقييم استراتيجيتها في
غزه والنظر في مدى قدرتها على مواجهه خطر
خروج الوضع في غزه عن السيطره بالاضافه
الى تقييم الخسائر والتكاليف الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه لهدفها المتمثل في بسط السيطره
الكامله على غزه كل هذا في ظل الضغوط
المتزايده للراي العام
الدولي في صحيفه الجارديان نقرا للوزير
البريطاني السابق بيتر هين قوله ان
اسرائيل لن تتمكن من تدمير حماس حتى لو
دمرت غزه باكملها مؤكد على ضروره اشراك
حماس في حكم غزه بعد انتهاء الحرب ويرى
هين ان الغرب متواطئ فيما سماه الفشل
الذريع في غزه ويحذر من ان الفجوه بين
العواصم الغربيه والجنوب العالمي تتسع وان
ثمن ذلك سيكون
باهضا في الفاينانشال تايمز تقرير يتحدث
عن حجم الدمار في غزه ويتساءل عن الواقع
الذي سيتعين على سكان غزه التعامل معه في
اليوم التالي للحرب حسب التقرير كثيرون في
غزه يدركون ان هدف اسرائيل هو تحويل
القطاع الى مكان غير صالح للعيش ثم يعلق
التقرير بالقول ان سكان غزه تعودوا الخروج
من بين الانقاذ الى الحياه من
جديد